BEGIN IN THIRTY SECONDS. THANK
YOU. I THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES WILL COME TO ORDER LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEARNING HERE ON IN HERE ROTH-
ROCK HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILL
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU I LET ME I'D DO AN
OFFICIAL WELCOME TO SHOULD NOT
CHEN WHO IS THE NEW SECRETARY
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
WELCOME YOU OFFICIALLY. SENATOR
BIGGS GIVEN ONES- I AM GOING TO
RECOGNIZE HER NOW AND I THOUGHT
SINCE THE SECRETARY CALLED THE
ROLE- SO NOW- I WANT TO THE A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
GOOD AFTERNOON. IN RESPONSE TO
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENT TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE COMPLY
WITH THOSE ORDERS WERE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SENATOR BATES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WITH THE
USE OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE
SYSTEM SHE WILL NOT VOTING
TODAY. BUT SENATOR BATES LET ME
RECOGNIZE YOU AND WELCOME YOU
REMOTELY IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT- RIGHT NOW IS YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIRMAN IT GETS LIKE GREAT TO
SEE YOU ALL I WISH I COULD BE
THERE WITH YOU THAT. THING HERE
IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE WE ARE
GETTING A LOT OF WORK DONE AND
BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY AND DANCES ARE VERY-
SATISFYING SO. I CARRY ON AND
I'LL BE LISTENING VERY CLOSELY
TO ALL OF THE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES. AYE AT THIS
TIME I AND I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
COULD PARTICIPATE- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ACCOMMODATE
OUR MEMBERS. AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WE RECOGNIZE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. ISSUES OF THE FOREST
CENTER BAY TO MAY ONE OF MUTE
YOUR PHONE- OUR COMPUTER ARE
AYE KEY PERSONNEL WILL MUTE AND
UNMUTE THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. AND THAT'LL
GREATLY AIDED ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK- AND IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION YOU
CAN USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. AND
ONCE RECOGNIZED SPEAK- YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO GO FORWARD. THERE
MAY BE A LITTLE BIT OF A LAG
TIME A FEW TECHNICAL ISSUESAS
WE PROCEED TODAY. SO LET'S BE
PATIENT WE'LL GET THROUGH IT
QUICKLY ALTHOUGH OUR AGENDA
TODAY IS FAIRLY. FAIRLY QUICK
AND ONLY ONE ITEM SO WE ARE
PRACTICING OBVIOUSLY FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE. ITEM ONE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA IS THE REFERENCE OF
BILLS- I AM HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION REMOVED. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. MAN
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. MINING
ALL RIGHT MONNING AYE ROTH
RIGHT ROTH AYE WILK ALL RIGHT
WILK I ATKINS AYE ATKINS I FOUR
EIGHT ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY- THAT IS OUR
WORK FOR TODAY A SENATOR BATES
THANK YOU THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
ARE MEETING IS ADJOURNED.